Mitch Kessler my co-host
was fired today.
Ahhhhhh!
The network that I gave 20 years
of my life, is locking me out.
You left me in the woods
with a pack of wolves
I am so mad at you.
There had to be a
million and one
women out there, who didn't
work on The Morning Show.
I think that you're jealous
because of our history.
You're not impartial
on this subject.
And you're impartial?
This is a good time to start
grooming some new people.
I just need to be able to
control the narrative
so that I am not
written out of it.
You don't have the
power anymore.
We are doing this my way.
My new Morning Show co-host
is Bradley Jackson.
Your show sucks.
Thank you.
It's barely news.
Was there something about
the network that made it
impossible to complain?
What the hell's she doing?
Did you know about Mitch?
I'm down the road on an
investigative piece
looking into the upper
levels of UBA.
We didn't know, right?
Right.
I want you to interview
me on the show.
I could give you who else knew
about what was going on.
We have an opportunity here
to do something
truly meaningful.
This is...
Dramatic.
Thrilling.
He wants everybody,
that includes me.
Bradley's got to go.
You and I would make a
great partnership.
You have no idea how much
I've waited to hear these words.
♪♪
You said you have someone who
could corroborate
Fred's direct complicity.
It's Hannah, she's dead.
Are we doing this?
We would like to share some
information about our network.
Get everything.
There are some really bad
things going on here.
None of us are going to lie
to you anymore.
We cannot accept a culture of
silen-
♪♪